definitely appreciate how much work goes
into doing these you know when you go to
a venue and you watch a show with like
with a thousand people or something yeah
maybe you realize just how many moving
Parts oh there are a lot you know a lot
of people
um were like damn why aren't they coming
to my place or whatever it's like well
it's it's very [ __ ] difficult to
organize a tour yeah and it kind of
sucks a lot of people like why the US
um well the US isn't a very unique uh
place where it is actually like built
for tours yeah
um you know a lot of the time when
you're moving merch across borders and
that's how a lot of these shows I didn't
realize this either a lot of these
concerts only make like most of their
profits through the merch yeah like
ticket sales you don't actually get that
much money because a lot of the cot like
the venue's expensive everything else is
expensive all the staff like yeah you as
this like talent and the the kind of
agency or whatever you don't make much
money from the tickets yeah and the US
is in a prime position where you can
actually drive around all the same
country where all the same like rules
with selling merch it's all the laws
because I think we learned a lot just
from doing this U.S tour because there
were a lot of complaints being like oh
they they've had they hate the entire
world because everyone just goes to the
us so we did one show in Canada and I
think like the only time we got like
negative feedback from our show yeah was
from that one show in Canada and that
was to do with there was like we we had
the show in Canada and uh we didn't
realize that there were different laws
in terms of bringing merch across the
border different laws of hiring staff
members because all staff members need
to be hired locally yeah um and there
was a lot of logistical things that just
weren't within like our Radars when we
sorted out we didn't know that we didn't
know that but obviously the tool company
knew that but obviously still you know
trying to get like the merch shipments
to arrive on time I didn't realize this
was a problem but yeah that that's a
whole thing yeah that's that needs to be
taken care of so yeah a lot of the times
you're kind of hoping that all the
moving pieces would work sometimes they
don't and it's like what do we do yeah
yeah we ended up like like shipping 12
boxes of merch to our Canada show and
one arrived and then we had one day to
get as much merch made locally in Canada
as we could unfortunately it wasn't as
much merch as we had in our us shows but
that's kind of like the things that
people don't think about and don't know
about because you know when uh you know
if you do a tour in multiple countries
every country has their own laws every
country has their own taxes it's not
just getting people from One venue to
another you know it's so what we're
trying to say is hit the game not the
player obviously it can be done these
people do it but it's just it's it's
harder it is our first tour the US makes
a lot of sense yeah this was also our
first tour as well so we had so many
things that I guess we just didn't know
until it happened I mean thankfully I'd
like to say that the tour was a massive
success I didn't see any negative
reviews no I'm so glad because like we
we one of the biggest things I was
worried about free tour was that we'd
start doing like shows and people would
like you know I've seen feedback before
of like you know people that have gone
on tours and you know I've seen the
feedback of just like oh it wasn't
really worth the money I spent all this
money seeing it just wasn't really worth
it I'm like thankfully it felt like
everyone had a good time and we put on a
good show that we brought to like
different places and I was just like
after I think it was like after the
first show that I actually had like
faith in our show I guess because well
we had the outline of the show and we
didn't actually we'd never rehearsed it
we didn't really know how it was going
to go until the rehearsals which was two
days before yeah our actual show yeah
and like our show relied so much on like
crowd interaction and having a rehearsal
in front of like five people versus like
the thousand people that we had in our
actual show was like night and day in
terms of like Vibe and chemistry and
stuff like that
um so I was going through rehearsals I
was like I think we have a good show but
I'm not sure I think as well it was it
was tough for us because you know we do
stuff in front of a camera right yeah
and doing stuff in front of a camera
like this or like the videos that we do
personally is very different to putting
on a show on stage right and you know
some people will be like oh but you guys
are used to you know doing panels at
conventions and stuff like that it's a
very different feel yeah you know a
panel is a million times easier than
what what we were what we had to do on
stage I was [ __ ] knackered after
everything oh yeah I I was I like it
drained me yeah so much and that and
that's because like we actually tried to
make it a show rather than just make it
you know trash podcast on stage it was
really cool getting to see you guys like
from the first show like the 10th show
how much you guys quickly improved yeah
being on stage it was really [ __ ]
sick yeah it was awesome yeah I I think
by like the like halfway point we all
had like a rhythm and yeah yeah we knew
how to like bounce off each other what
worked well with the crowd what didn't
work so well with the crowds I also
noticed we had like just without even
discussing it necessarily we had like
certain jokes that we knew the kind of
Rhythm too yeah and like where to place
it and like because it was always you
know you you do the the show and then
you kind of noticed oh okay this joke
kind of hit maybe I can try it again in
the next show and then without thinking
like I knew exactly when say like Conor
o'gart were going to say specific jokes
and you exactly kind of the feel and
Rhythm to go with it right yeah yeah
like you know God would do like the one
piece's real thing at the beginning yes
which always popped off right and I
always knew to sing can we get much
higher you know so it was just kind of
like it was it's this weird thing of it
started off as very much like a an
impromptu ad-lib filled script like you
know non scripted show yeah but then I
feel by the end of it it kind of turned
into like almost a scripted show in a
weird way it was like like we had
segments that we didn't know what was
going to happen and segments that was
kind of like scripted yeah that we kind
of knew how to like transition between
segments and stuff like that definitely
and play off the audience and stuff like
that
um but like having said that you know I
I'd say that every show did have a lot
of like Variety in in them
um and we kind of did that by Design and
it was very very interesting to see how
what what the different vibe in each
city was we definitely learned a lot
about I guess like the diversity of
crowds in the US I I think what I what I
enjoyed most about the shows was
actually like our show was our way to
learn about that particular area and we
got we I learned a lot that you couldn't
just get by Googling yeah what are the
top five like uh what are the top five
most famous things about this one era
yeah right it was really really
interesting to see what certain states
and cities were really passionate about
yeah they want
um yeah that was fun because a lot of
the times it was very surprising yeah
and you know a lot of the times you've
got questions because we did a q a
before every show uh and people would
always ask you know did the tour change
your opinion on the US at all and how
did you guys answer yes and no yeah
because yes some things did change but
it doubled down like 10 other things oh
God yeah we kept having like an argument
about like we're like is the us more
diverse than they they claim or is it
because right oh yeah I think the US is
more diverse than say the UK compared to
Australia I was like you're full of [ __ ]
like that's nice I I didn't say that I I
said it felt like like going from uh
West Coast to East Coast I felt like
going from like say LA to New York to me
felt more different than going to London
to Sydney I I I and I still believe that
I gen I genuinely believe should I be
offended as an Australian yes
why is that offensive
it's like not even close what about
Australians are a different breed of
people yeah they're like I don't think
so I don't think so I would understand
the comparison between say like
Australia and New Zealand uh that that's
a little more understandable but like
Australia and England voters are
different we're different
yeah
I think I think culturally culturally
yeah you know I think Australians and
Brits have a lot in common oh of course
we have like a very similar sense of
humor we have a very similar I I I agree
there's comparisons there what do you
think of the differences then between
the west coast and the East Coast Vibes
um I think like I think the vibe in east
coast is like totally different from
west coast East Coast they like talk
faster they are much more direct with
the way they like speak and I I agree
with that you know like West Coast or
like way more chilled they're a bit more
flowery with their language and their
words whereas you know with East Coast
it's kind of like you know they talk way
faster and things move faster in the
East Coast close than the West Coast you
know I think I you know I because when I
went to Sydney for example when I went
to Sydney
um I was like damn this kind of feels
like London with good weather you know I
I was looking you know that changes the
game though that that's uh that's
everything the weather is everything no
no you know I remember the exact words
you said you were like wow you you know
you you hung out in Sydney for like
three days and you were like this is
like the UK except if everyone was happy
yeah I was like yeah that's like going
to other European countries like it's
like the UK but different language it's
like it's like no no no no no I I think
I think I think you know different
countries in Europe are [ __ ] totally
different in terms of like Vibes and
cultures and everything like that I was
just saying I think the UK and like UK
and Australia have a lot similar
culturally when you're comparing London
and Sydney which are two cities the UK
is very diverse throughout and you know
you can't compare Scotland to like
London yeah okay I would say there's a
bigger difference between like Dublin
and London you know yeah like Dublin
feels like a different country than yeah
okay okay but okay London let's say
let's say England then let's say England
because England to me is London and then
everywhere else London has like have you
gone to the north I I have been to the
North Korea okay okay where have you got
what's the most how far north yeah how
far north of Liverpool
not North it's Louisville it's Northern
come on North but it's not it's not
North North it's not Yorkshire it's not
[ __ ] God because I've been to
Liverpool many times bro I've been to
Grimsby once it did not feel like
Liverpool right I don't know I I think
that I I think it's hard to you can
judge cities a lot easier especially
like London and Sydney because yeah well
Sydney was kind of built like London in
a sense yeah there are sections of
Sydney that look very similar to
something you would find in London
um but I think if you're comparing the
culture of the country like as Australia
to the England it's very different it's
showed different it's night and day do
you think so why'd you okay what do you
think what do you think is like so
different about it then because Jen
Johnny okay this is now yeah now you
have to ask what is the culture we're
doing this again well what makes up
right so like are we talking just the
people are we talking because like you
know if you're talking how they have
their own dialect essentially they talk
very differently they're Australia has
its own language yeah yeah yeah they
have you know they have uh its own
native population which is totally
different as well which plays an impact
they don't play the same Sports a lot of
the times as us they've AFL and they'll
play some of them are cricket and rugby
but you know they do play other sports
yes yeah um they have Sun that's a big
one
we have good beaches that changes the
game quite frankly okay okay what okay
here's I think animals they're
completely different Landscapes
you can say that with a place like
America you know you go to [ __ ]
Florida [ __ ] Gators you go to
Colorado
there's native populations in America
obviously as well and it depends a lot I
don't know it feels weird because no
matter where you go right and no matter
how much local differences okay they
never quite lose that kind of
americanness that they they always have
whereas like certain traits that I think
Americans often have right I think that
just never really so you always even
though you're in Seattle you're in
Florida it always feels like America is
that that feeling never really goes no
matter which at least from the mainland
I've never been to Hawaii or I mean
Hawaii they've been to Alaska I don't
know how that feels but yeah it always
still feels America like it can never
quite shake that that kind of the The
Vibes that Americans have in a weird way
yeah I'm I mean I'm I'm saying I do
think you know there is some kind of
like american-ness in the feeling and
stuff like that but I'm saying like
there is a lot of like I go into
different parts of America it's like
there was a lot of like different there
was like there was like some
similarities but I've never felt like
such such a dichotomy of like different
mentalities and different ways of
thinking in the same country before like
well as I was saying the reason I I
brought up the UK and Australia is that
to me I it feels like you know UK are
like oh I'm gonna say England okay
because I'm mostly talking about England
yeah English people and Australian
people feel like they're cut from the
same cloth but they just have different
starting like parameters you know but I
feel like we're we're kind of cut from
the same cloth I you know you a lot of
English people get along well with
Australians I mean we're [ __ ] same
brain cell and [ __ ] like that even
though we grew up like halfway across
the world from each other you know what
I mean I feel like culturally we have
like the same sense of humor a lot of
the times we kind of think it's very
similar we have like you know we have
our different cultures that depend on
you know where we are in the world and
everything like that and like the
wildlife and the geography and all that
stuff but I feel like at its core we you
know we think a lot of the same ways
whereas in America you go to like
different stages like there is such a
big difference going from a red state to
a blue State it's like you you feel like
I agree with that and obviously a lot of
a lot of Americans will be watching this
they're like yo I don't want to be
[ __ ] grouped in with like Nebraska
yeah I don't want to be grouped in with
Florida yeah and that happens a lot so a
lot of Americans are always real really
feel patriotic a lot of the time about
their state or where they are yeah
um and I agree yeah there are a lot of
differences but again like I said it
still feel like you never feel like
you've left America in a sense and like
I I very much feel like I'm not in the
UK when I'm when I'm in Australia when I
was there it definitely didn't feel like
it at all to me right I don't know I
know I was like walking around like
Sydney and I saw like pubs and I saw
like chippies and like chicken shops I
was like [ __ ] I feel like I'm in London
right now I kind of feel like I'm at
home right now I don't know again like I
said earlier it's hard to compare cities
right because the cities more often than
not like I I you get more Australian the
more you leave a city right yeah that's
true that's true I mean you know when I
went outside of London for the first
time you know like towards like the
countryside yeah yeah like you know
Chris took me to like Salisbury and like
you know other places like that I'm just
like this is definitely not like this is
just like as British as I get the
[ __ ] gets